kind of Comedy that he was writing we
talked about this a little bit last time
was old comedy
which was very raw it tended to take
people from the actual city of Athens
sometimes other places too and put them
into these these crazy situations make
fun of people there was actually like a
part of the play like I told you about
where the actors would take off their
masks come down into the audience and
just start yelling at people you are a
terrible person because you did this wow
that guy getting it so it's sort of like
a roast at a certain point if you watch
the uncensored ones pretty you know
vicious stuff but we get a kick out of
that and the ancient Greeks got a kick
out of that too you know part of Comedy
is watching people trip over things and
fall down and provided it's not you or
somebody who care about us it can be
funny so Aristophanes is part of that
genre